[Music]
Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas's
one-year-old daughter makes her British
Vogue debut and inside the mag the
actress opens up about surrogacy Maltese
birth and being a first-time Mom I love
kids I always have loved kids Priyanka
looking Fab on the cover of British
vogue's February issue she poses it up
with her baby girl both dressed in red
malty turned away from the camera you
have to make peace with the fact that
we're in a public job while Priyanka and
Nick have shared several pics of multi
on social media they have yet to show
her face how's fatherhood been for you
because everybody says it's
life-changing to you it is certainly
life-changing she's uh she's amazing
um brings me a lot of Joy all is good
the couple announced malty's birth in
January 2022 and and revealed she was
born via surrogate but it wasn't until
five months after that that the two
revealed multi spent more than 100 days
in the hospital following her birth
in the mag Priyanka shuts down internet
trolls who accused her of using a
surrogate out of vanity she explained
she had medical complications and using
a surrogate was a necessary step and
when it comes to public criticism she's
developed a tough hide but it's painful
when people talk about her baby girl
quote I've been really protective of
this chapter of my life with my daughter
because it's not about my life only it's
hers too to put it bluntly Priyanka
tells the haters quote you don't know me
you don't know what I've been through
and just because I don't want to make my
medical history or my daughter's public
doesn't give you the right to make up
whatever the reasons were honey no
multi had to be delivered pre-term a
full trimester before her due date and
Priyanka tells the mag that for the next
three months they had to shuttle daily
to neonatal intensive care quote we
spent every single day with her on my
chest on my husband's chest I didn't
know if she would make it or not in May
2022 Nick shared this sweet pick with
his wife and daughter after they brought
multi-home from the hospital writing in
the caption that while it was a
challenging few months it was abundantly
clear in retrospect how precious and
perfect every moment is it's a special
thing and shortly after Nick told ET he
sings for his little one you know I love
the singer and
um yeah you know it's it's beautiful
what's on the playlist are you singing
Love Bug uh no I'm singing just a lot of
you know old classics my wife kind of
plays her more of a stuff that's on the
iPod
and he opened up about how fatherhood
has changed him it has changed
everything for the better of course and
um yeah I think it's just always about
doing the best you can to take care of
yourself and never get it right 100 of
the time but uh I I do my best
[Music]